je trouve que c'est bien pour protéger
la population mais le problème c'est
qu'il ya des masques nulle part donc
comment on va faire pour ce pour en
acheter ou sont procurés que je vais
mettre un truc sur le visage qui a une
espèce de kaboul de moto doit que ça
sinon sûr que c'est exagéré ce qu'on
croit qu'une personne fait empêche je
pense que je vais très comme ça
il n'a pas parlé de masse qui a parlé de
protection donc on les a naturellement
parce que les masses et la question où
les chercher je pense une bonne chose ça
se fait partie des barrières qu'il faut
mettre moi je suis pas content parce que
je pense que si ça peut protéger
l'ensemble des personnes de la région
maintenant mieux